Donc, là, c'est les étagères. Tu mets ce que tu veuxdessus.
-Ok !
Et puis derrière la caméra, du coup, y a Stéphane !
Et là, bah, Christophe va te régler le micro...
-Ok !
Léa... Tu sais que ça va aller ?
Oui, je sais... Mais c'est pas facile de partir, même pour de
nouvelles aventures, c'est...
-Je sais.
-Bon ! Allez !
-Merci Léa !
Eh bien bonjour à tous, moi c'est Marie, et c'estdésormais à mes côtés que vous allez savourer
votre Zeste de Science. Vous m'avez peut-être
d'ailleurs déjà croisée sur internet, où j'aime
bien vulgariser les sciences au travers de sujets
insolites...
-Oui enfin cela me permet surtout de
lire dans l'obscurité.
-Tout le monde pense que je peux pas me poser au sol mais c'est juste que je veux pas !
Vous verrez, on ne risque pas de
s'ennuyer ensemble, car ici on s'intéresse à toutes
les disciplines, à partir des images réalisées
par les scientifiques lors d'expériences, de
modélisations ou d'observations... Mais ça, si vous
nous suivez, vous le savez déjà !
Et abonnez-vous !